Unknown unknown's,
well,
unknown,
unknown unknowns,
leap at you from places that you
wouldn't expect because otherwise you
would have planned for the damn thing.
So there are the things that are always
like poking their beak off at you when
you least expect it.
They're just like,
say serpents in the garden of Eden.
That might be one way of thinking about
it.
You can't keep the damn snakes out of
the garden and that's because you can't
make a bounded area and keep the
complexity out of it.
The complexity always sneaks back in.
Try protecting your children from the
Internet.
For example.
You can't make a bounded circumstance
and get rid of all the complexity.
It always comes sneaking back in.
So what would be an unknown?
Unknown.
This is a good one.
Here.
You have an intimate relationship.
You've had it for 10 years.
You Trust your partner,
so what does that mean?
You know what,
where you are,
you know who you are and you have a
pretty good idea of who of where you're
going,
and then one day you'll find out that
your partner has been cheating on you,
not with one person but with three
people and for the whole 10 years.
Well,
hypothetically,
that comes as a shock.
Although you may have ignored many
intimations that such might be the case
irrelevant.
Let's say it comes as a shock.
Well,
what happens to you?
you don't know where you are.
You don't know where you've been.
That's interesting.
Okay,
because you think you know where you've
been because you've already been there,
but all of a sudden something can happen
so that you are so flipped over that you
don't even know where you were.
So that means in some sense,
the past is dependent on the present.
A very peculiar thing.
You also have no idea where you're going
in terms of not knowing where you are.
That's Deep Bay because you might think,
well,
I know I thought it was in a marriage
that turns out to be wrong.
I thought I knew who my wife or husband
was that turns out to be wrong.
I concluded on the basis that I knew my
wife,
that I knew something about women that
turned out to be wrong.
I thought I was in a relationship with
someone I could trust that is wrong.
I don't know enough about trust.
I'm obviously too gullible and so what
that does is throw virtually everything
that's ever happened to me in severe
doubt,
right?
That's the emergence of chaos and that
yes,
sometimes you're going from point a to
point b and something you don't expect
manifests itself in the middle of your
plan,
but it's not such a catastrophe because
you can just work around it and then
sometimes something pops up and like you
just do not have a plan anymore,
and so then you might ask yourself just
exactly where you are.
You when you don't know where you are,
and I would say that's our place and
it's actually a place that's well
documented in classic religious and
mythological stories.
That's chaos.
The Dallas,
for example,
they believe that the world is made out
of chaos and order order.
That's where you,
when you do gets you what you want,
chaos.
That's where you are.
When you have no idea what's going on
and you might ask,
well,
is there a way that you should act when
you're in chaos and the answer to that
is there better be because it's a place
you're going to visit several times
during your life and everyone visits
that.
That's why it's an archetypal story.
That's the dissent to the underground.
Underground is that horrible place that
lurks underneath all of our
presuppositions.
It's the frigid lake underneath the thin
ice that everybody's skating on and it's
something that can manifest itself at
any moment.
That's partly why in the Dallas
Assemble,
the Black Paisley is chaos by the way,
and the White Paisley is ordered in the
order Paisley.
There's a little black dot.
Well,
that's because order can turn into chaos
and does at any moment,
and the reverse is also true chaos.
Paternity to order at any moment and
insight will do that for you.
You know,
alcoholics report that when they hit
bottom,
it's like there's a patella system.
They look at the world in a different
way.
You know,
now they're a new person.
They're back from an underground.
They've risen from the dead,
so to speak.
You know,
and it's partly because what it looks
like,
your right hemisphere is pretty good at.
I'm inferring patterns in,
in,
in novel and chaotic places.
It's kind of keeping track of things
that happened to you that are anomalous
and it makes alternative maps of the
world that are there for you to rely on,
at least to some degree if that ever
becomes necessary.